this video is sponsored by my partner
geology there's a new kind of fake gamer
On The Rise and I for one I'm sick of it
you mean to tell me we're just letting
these people walk the streets pretending
that they play video games having
opinions on video games and they don't
even like video games not on my watch
I'm not having it genuinely though this
is a thing and I do think these people
are kind of causing problems and that I
have also contributed to those problems
and it only occurred to me recently and
so I wanted to make this video which I'm
sure is going to upset some people but
here we are there is a recent and
growing culture of people who just like
hate video games being very involved in
video game communities I see it in my
comment sections all the time and I'm
always like a little confused by it
anytime that I've mentioned in any video
the amount of good games that came out
in 20123 there's always this response of
people being like actually old games
[__] look at all the bad games that came
out this year the day before I always
have to look it up cuz I forget the name
of the game Skull Island rise of Kong
Gollum all these terrible video games
all games as [__] they all have battle
passes and microtransactions and they're
all garbage which to me just directly
translates to you don't play many video
games like if you think that all games
have those problems or that all games
suck you're kind of firsthand admitting
that you don't like video games right
that's what you're telling me so that's
my first thesis here if you're the kind
of person who says all video games are
[__] you're not playing the Right video
games there are a lot of really great
video games that have come out this year
there are literally more than I would
have time to play you would have trouble
while also having a life even finishing
the amount of games that would very very
very good that were not predatory and
did not have predatory practices that
came out in 2023 if you tell me all
video games are [__] these days I
suspect that you only play really
specific kinds of AAA games like really
specific like repetitive potentially
exploitative releases and that I hope
that you're able to broaden your Horizon
on the kind of games that you play
because that is an issue if you only
play games you don't like or only play
Bad Games not only are you not going to
like video games you're also going to be
giving those things money and thus
creating more the reason that we keep
getting battle passes is because people
keep buying battle passes when people
talk about like vote with your wallet
with video games the problem is we are
voting without wallets the games
Community is repeatedly telling
Publishers that it will spend money on
microtransactions and battle passes and
pre-orders dear God stop pre-ordering
video games I don't know why people do
this and I wanted to make this video for
two reasons one to tell you about some
of the amazing games that came out this
year and two to talk about like the
separate parts of this problem okay now
I'm not absolving the games industry of
a lot of issues there are a lot of
issues isues the problem that I have
noticed is a culture of perpetuating the
issues which again I've contributed to I
think this is only happened more
recently we used to just forget about
bad games but now when we talk about a
game like the day before which again I
had to look at the name of cuz I always
forget what it's called cuz it's so
[__] generic this was a game that
effectively got skyrocketed to
popularity because everybody assumed it
would be a scam and then it came out and
it was bad and then the servers were
getting shut down I actually haven't
played it in considered making a video
about it and um that's sort of when I
realized the problem that I know about
this bad game you know about this bad
game I would be telling you more about
this bad game and I'm not going to tell
you that I'm not going to play Bad Games
again it's funny but why continue to
perpetuate the bad and signal boost the
bad so much when there are literally
more good games than most of us can even
afford to buy the same thing happened
with Skull Island rise of Kong and the
same thing happened with Golem which
again I played on this very channel for
longer than I played games that I really
liked this year I didn't play a game
like dredge which is like absolutely one
of my favorite games of the year I did
speak about it but I didn't play it here
and we basically created this culture of
like really really really signal
boosting bad video games to the extent
that I think it might be happening
intentionally in some cases by spending
so much time highlighting the things we
don't like which there are things in
games that I think are the worst that
they've ever been there are things that
I think are really really really bad if
you know me you know I'm very anti-
microtransaction I've only bought one
ever and it was a dog and sea of Thieves
rare is one of my favorite Studios I'm
happy to support them I won't buy battle
passes for any game ever I feel
negatively about plenty of parts of the
live service push because it means that
we are getting less video games overall
and instead are getting more video games
that want to consume and steal all of
our time like that I think is a really
negative part of the video game industry
that that there are certain Publishers
that are trying to shift heavily towards
specifically live services in the
interest of monetizing the amount of
hours that you play in a different way
and thus they kind of have to forcibly
make GES more addictive to keep you
engaged in that one game to keep getting
money from you for a thousand hours or
whatever like that I think is a whole
mindfield that maybe I should make a
separate video about predatory practice
in the games industry or things that I'm
really concerned about I definitely been
meaning to make a video about
advertising and how bad I think that's
going to get so maybe I'll do that soon
this video is not about that there are
things that I think are negative and I
don't think we should ignore those
negative things they should be spoken
about the problem is the speaking
doesn't help very much not only are we
advertising the games that we don't like
in a lot of cases and again not talking
about the games that that we do like but
like I said gamers are already kind of
voting with their wallets we are already
buying microtransactions battle passes
that is why Publishers keep doing it you
can scream about how much you don't like
it but that is what the industry is
telling them is working or as long as
that keeps happening that is not going
to change no matter how angry you are on
the internet about it unfortunately and
I think this year especially having
Skull Island rise of Kong and Gollum and
the day before and that Walking Dead
game that looked absolutely terrible all
come out in the same year I think we are
actually moving to a movement where we
are incentivizing bad video games it is
time to talk about geology geology is a
skincare solution that takes all of the
honestly very hard work out of skincare
I only started learning about skincare
extremely recently and when I started
trying to find out any information I was
just overwhelmed by the amount of
different products and different
ingredients and what's good for what and
why geology makes it super super simple
you take a quiz which is very quick and
they make a simple and effective routine
that works for you the products are
built around a handful of powerful
proven ingredients so you aren't doing a
million confusing steps you don't know
in what order it even labels like 1 2 3
tells you exactly the order to use
things in so you know I will also say
all of their products feel really silky
and lightweight they don't feel overly
greasy or like they're like clogging
your face in any way and they smell
really nice not too strong which I feel
like is a huge plus and obviously this
works for a lot of people geology is a
26 time award-winning skin hair and body
care company recognizing Publications
like Men's Health hype Beast birdie
Esquire osmen and Oprah daily grooming
Awards they have over 7,000 fstar
reviews and have a track record of
transforming Skeptics into loyalists so
right now for a limited time they are
hooking you up with an absolutely insane
offer use my code Char alazard 70 or
scan the QR code that is on screen and
they will give you an exclusive 70% off
their award-winning skincare trial set
on top of that you can get 50% off the
add-on products of your choice when you
add it to your trial this is one of the
best offers you'll see so make sure you
get it before it's gone that code is
charazard 70 and the company is geology
g o l o g b i e now back to the video I
think we are maybe months away from
probably smaller Studios who don't care
as much about their reputations I think
there is one that has already done this
intentionally making rage bait bad video
games because they know that content
creators will play them for free it's
very hard to get a content creator to
play a game that you worked very hard on
and really like unless it exists as a
well-known IP in the AAA space turns out
getting people to play really really bad
video games even the smallest content
creators will do it is really really
easy to the extent that it is now I
think we've created a legitimate
business strategy the specific publisher
that I wanted to call out is a company
called game Mill game Mill made Skull
Island rise of Kong and a report from
The Verge revealed that game Mill gave
iguan B the developer only one year to
build the game from scratch beginning
June 2022 which is insanity you can't
make a game in one year priately two to
20 developers were working on the game
at any given time and the game required
to Crunch in order to even finish the
project which still came out very bad
unfortunately it received super negative
reviews people said the game was ugly
full of bugs very boring does nothing
meaningful or new or clever at all
terrible visuals horrendous gameplay
awful level design just overwhelmingly
excessively negative and of course the
publisher knew about this they rushed
the game out within a year for some
reason and now all of us know what it is
this game has been so hotly spoken about
so much more than any of the good games
that came out in 2023 another game also
from game Mill entertainment had similar
release this year The Walking Dead
Destiny came out November 17 and it's
considered to be one of the worst games
of 2023 with OE Reynolds from Nintendo
life saying there is absolutely nothing
here that has been executed well it's a
game that is simply Rife with technical
blunders terrible production values and
broken mechanics two games from game
Mill that were probably created under
the exact same circumstances that got so
much attention for being bad watch
whatever game Mill's next game is that's
all I'm trying to say I think we have
potentionally unintentionally created a
culture of certain publish is being like
wait if we make a bad game and it only
takes a year to make and with limited
stuff and we make them crunch for free a
bunch of people will buy it so they can
talk about it this seemingly will only
work if it's an IP because it kind of
requires us to recognize the property
but we have created a legitimate
business strategy for low-level or
mid-level Publishers who previously have
a record of publishing some more
creative titles you can kind of get more
creative and take more risks in that
space there's less to lose in conclusion
we give a lot of attention
to things we don't like in video games I
think there are a lot of people who
involve themselves in video game culture
who don't even really play video games
and instead just watch Angry YouTubers a
lot of whom as it turns out also don't
even really play video games we do not
spend anywhere near enough time talking
about the games that we actually do like
and rewarding the things that we
actually do like I think the gaming
community did a great job with balers
Gate 3 this year buying that game
telling the industry that you want
something of that scale that is a huge
win for everybody but we still got a
bunch of fake Gamers walking Among Us
and I fully feel that way about anybody
who says all games are [__] now all
games are bad now are they the only way
you can think that is if you don't
really play video games and you only pay
attention to people on YouTube there's a
lot that's wrong I'm not removing that
and a lot that's bad and a lot that I
find very concerning as someone who
really loves video games but there were
so many good games this year that my
guess is you just haven't heard of them
you just don't know about them because
you don't really pay that much attention
to video games it's okay to admit that
fake gamer in conclusion I'm going to
leave you with a bunch of these here are
what I think are some absolutely
incredible games that came out in 2023 a
lot of which have not gotten as much
attention as Gollum or Kong or The
Walking Dead or the day before and that
sucks if you think all video games suck
try any of these I'm not going to go
with the super obvious picks that
everyone's picking like balers Gate 3
and Zelda and alleno 2 so let's start
with a franchise you probably heard of
but a series that I feel like never ever
ever gets enough love this is zener
Blade Chronicles 3 future redeemed this
game is in my opinion absolutely
incredible it has a lot of strength in
both combat and exploration and I think
they really nail the pacing it is so
sharp and so fastpaced unless you don't
want it to be it's totally opt in and
the story especially if you've played
the other games is one of its best I
think it stands by itself quite
effectively and if you've never played
any of the games you will miss a little
bit of context I'd recommend just
watching YouTube videos but you will
otherwise still have a really really
rewarding experience playing it is
basically Zeno Blade Chronicles
realizing what it was trying to be the
whole time getting rid of previous
issues that some of the other games had
in my opinion and coming up with
something that is effectively the best
of it J next up is Against The Storm
which is obviously a very particular
type of game but again if you're the
kind of person who thinks all games suck
maybe try something that's outside of
the usual genre that's not the action
adventure that so much of the triaa
space leans to it's kind of a mixture of
strategy And Rog likee elements there is
a ton of randomly generated content
which means that every single time you
play things are going to feel incredibly
different and of course it has a really
satisfying gameplay Loop taking
essentials from other really well-known
games in this particular genre but it
also just has an un unbelievably like
undeniably addictive gameplay loop again
I know this is a really particular kind
of game but if you're happy with
everything that you're playing right now
check it out it is one of the most
positively reviewed games on Steam of
the year it has tons of charm and is
incredibly unique like super unique it
is like almost nothing else I have ever
played next is Turbo Overkill and oh my
God is this game so awesome it really
takes the best elements of a lot of
older first person shooters again very
Doom inspired plus a bunch of Pop
Culture references that are really
really fun and everything it borrows it
borrows in a very smart Innovative way
so it never feels like a ripoff of
anything it feels like it has its own
identity but that it very carefully mly
almost took cues from every other game
that it should have if that makes sense
and I actually can't imagine many people
not liking this game unless you're just
really offut by an older aesthetic again
you really just like the shiny Graphics
of the AAA space or something it is just
so much fun so over the top such a
thrill to play I cannot recommend this
game enough next is Dave the diver which
did actually take off pretty well this
year it has a couple of different
gameplay Loops that I think complement
each other perfectly well you play as a
literal diver and some of the Dives are
quite compelling trying to capture f
fish to then sell in your restaurant it
is perfectly well directed every single
part of this game from art to music to
gameplay is all pushing in the same one
very satisfying Direction with and it
might surprise you initially a story
that actually has something very
interesting to say of course you upgrade
your little divea as you play along and
it's another one of those ones that I
want to be like play it I promise you no
gameplay I could show you will make this
game look as fun as it actually is but
it is very fulfilling very wholesome
still challenging and remarkably
creative this is one of the best games
of the here is no doubt and it's just so
so so unique Pizza Tower is a pretty
quick game for you to get through again
look how different all of these games
look isn't this cool talking me about
how all games suck and all games look
the same I'm having trouble even getting
through this list so Pizza Tower is very
very stylish sort of a warrior land type
it's a really clever silly over-the-top
animated platformer with some really fun
boss fights and an old school gameplay
style if you're sick of modern games
Jump Right In it also has one of my
favorite soundtracks of the year I
definitely would have nominated it if I
were onun any juries and I have
difficulty finding anything really to
flaw with it it is it's effectively a
perfect platformer next is slay the
princess which wow we getting creepy
this is a psychological horror visual
novel that has a beautiful art style a
really really fun and in my opinion
fairly unpredictable plot twist which is
especially kind of uncommon in the
Choose Your Own Adventure style which is
what this is it is an incredibly
in-depth Choice driven game I am so
impressed by The Narrative design in
this game it also has great characters
just tons of detail and I don't think
I've even scratched the surface of
everything that exists in this game just
yet next up is cocoon which is exactly
my [__] this is definitely one of my
games of the Year this is one of those
games similar to tunic for me where it
is just so expertly made that certain
components of it just become like
jaw-dropping just or inspiring
absolutely mind-blowingly incredible
it's a challenging puzzle game with
beautiful visuals really really strong
themes a lot of style in line with games
like inside which is in my top 10 games
ever features smart design top to bottom
plus some really really fun boss fights
next is dead cells return to Castlevania
which you may have heard me talk about
already on the channel if you like
Castlevania at all I think Castlevania
Symphony of the Night is probably still
the best PlayStation game at least it's
up there this is such a fantastic Ode to
the series combining obviously dead
cells Style with Castlevania style
there's a collaboration that I never
would have seen coming but they
absolutely nail it not much else I feel
like really needs to be said here just
two absolute goats being dead cells and
car lania combined to make something
pretty much perfect next up and for the
record I could keep going there is a lot
more that I could mention there are so
many more games that I could mention but
I tried to pick ones that are different
and ones that don't just fit the usual
AAA style like such a good year for
games tried to be just you know distinct
in what I picked here this is the Talis
principle too it is a very well-written
and very challenging puzzle game sort of
like the witness it's really
thought-provoking both tonally and in
story and in Puzzles not overly
difficult like you're not going to bash
your head against a wall playing it but
it's still really imaginative in a way
that I just find so impressive you'll
see things and hear things and talk to
people and have conversations in this
game that will make you think in a way
that I really really appreciated my time
with it like a oh huh I am better for
this game existing you also don't need
to have played the first game to play
the second one though I would personally
recommend it you like the portal if you
like the witness if you like anything
like that definitely check out tyus
principal 2 or any of the other
countless very very very good games that
came out in 2023 and come out every
single year if you're still here at the
end I doubt many people made it to the
end cuz the start of this video is where
the spice is can you just leave a
comment in the comment section saying
the word chicken just chicken I just
want to see how many if you made it to
the end all right a lot of video games
are really great y'all checking out